good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
2600 object class
uid containment attempt summary during
SC p 2600's containment operations
nonfunctional and other non-essential
test materials were cataloged by the
engineers of mobile task force Delta 43
quarter junkies SCP 2600 is currently
contained within site
77 all Personnel assigned to work with
SCP 2600 are to be rotated every 3 weeks
with regular psychiatric evaluations to
ensure they are not being affected by
SCP
2600 any physical interaction is to be
done by robotic
drones
description SCP 2600 designates a set of
eight CRT television sets connected to
one video computer system via a black
cable coming out of the cartridge slot
all external ports have been covered and
the copyright information on the bottom
of the unit has been replaced with a
label reading MK Pro 8 p images such as
graphical errors Ralph footage dating
from the Vietnam War video shot from A
View through a tank Periscope graphical
images resembling those found in SCP
1881 and SCP 1070 and non-anomalous game
Graphics have been documented on SCP
2600 the primary image displayed on SCP
2600 screens are several human faces
with varying levels of detail and
Clarity three adolescent subjects two
female and one male resembling youth two
were reported as missing during the year
1981 in the Portland Oregon region of
the United States one unidentified adult
subject interference with a signal
obscures the face leaving a white
silhouette although the hair and ears
come in clearly a male identified as a
former agent of the KGB who worked
within the United States reported
missing an action by the Soviet Union in
1991 two adult human subjects fale
who constantly mouthed the words setting
sail ships Us free and the kit case
jumped over the lazy
baly if a subject comes into physical
contact with any portion of SCP 2600
they will spontaneously generate
lysergic acid diamide in their oral
cavity usually resulting in
hallucinogenic effects adjusting the
switches present on the console portion
of SCP 2600 controls the emotional state
of the affected subject as well as
adjusting their responsiveness to
performing commands tested subjects
usually display sudden anger aggression
confusion sadness apathy and submission
this direct effect has been noted to
last between 20 minutes and 4 hours
after which subjects will return to
their normal behaviors the previous
sentence was stricken from the document
see
addendum history the anomaly currently
designated as SCP 2600 was first brought
to Foundation attention through Atari
Internal Documentation leaks in May of
1981 these leaks indicated that a war
simulation project contracted by the US
Army had exceeded its original scope and
the development team was now being led
by the Central Intelligence Agency one
subject was noted as having dramatic
behavioral changes after being recruited
by the CIA efforts to recover as CP 2600
were redoubled at this point recovered
documents indicate that CIA experiments
showed as SCP 2600 was capable of
affecting at least 200 subjects at once
and that it was possible to induce
affected individuals to work together in
completing tasks without being aware of
their
cooperation by the end of 1982 efforts
to prevent the anomaly from being
utilized by the United States had failed
resulting in the initial creation of SCP
2600 however the project was abandoned
due to unknown difficulties resulting in
it being transferred to the unusual
incidents unit Foundation agents were
able to recover SCP 2600 from them on
1983 as financial difficulties had
bankrupted Atari at this time Foundation
Personnel were able to confiscate all of
their materials relating to SCP 2600
Personnel involved in the development of
SCP 2600 remain under observation
particularly those involved with the
Central Intelligence Agency and the
unusual incidents unit addendum 2600
A1 analysis of site 77 has shown that
over the past 11 months since SCP 2600
was contained and classified several
unusual Trends have emerged these
include above average numbers of
volunteers for research and Analysis of
SCP 2600 surveillance records and
Communications testing electric usage
for the site 77 containment facilities
being abnormally high this has been
attributed to research staff leaving the
lights on at all hours of the day level
three personnel approving above average
numbers of research grants for projects
relating to SCP
2600 d-class Personnel not needing
instruction in regards to being tested
with a SCP 2600's anomalous
effect an unknown number of site 77
Personnel have been determined to have
been maliciously affected by a
previously unknown aspect of SCP 2600
immediate rotation of the containment
staff has been carried out by the
overseer Council and all affected
Personnel will be given Class B amnestic
treatments addendum 2600 C documentation
recovered from the initial creation of
SCP
2600 Stella project proposed by the
agency as a successor to
project due to the new materials
discovered which could overcome the
faults found in the original process of
implementing and sustaining controlling
people's
minds persons who were relieved of Duty
following the conclusion of the project
have been contacted by the agency in
order to resume some form of their
previous work work has been contracted
out to universities research foundations
and Compu computer companies including
the Atari Inc
Corporation their cooperation has proved
promising due to the presence of their
technology and contract to work with the
military in addition at least 80 former
employees of this company have signed on
to participate as dual
Personnel materials discovered from
rendevu with us Bureau of
Investigation the Arcadia effect the
human mind's ability to influence the
perceptions of other Minds once
liberated from the task of controlling a
body the effect appears to be entirely
contained to the mind and all outside
stimuli does nothing inhibit the effect
this includes usage of the experimental
T Echo chamber notably agents are to
note that thoughts of apathy
experiencing tenus and minor rashes
appearing around the temples are normal
side effects of exposure to to the
Arcadia effect in addition there have
been reports of vivid hallucinations of
broken sweaty pimply skin bumping up and
down on a bus with the shredded rubbery
not rubber wheels and some boy's mother
on the top the specificity of this
Vision has been consistent among those
experiencing it and have been found to
be mildly troubling to agents with a
psionic resistance index below
45 the these agents are not permitted to
with the object and its surrounding
equipment and related phenomenon
including the Dabney Zizi
inhibitor test subject in order to
experiment with the Arcadia effect
subjects must be completely liberated
from their old methods and abilities
regarding thought and logic to do so the
brain needs to focus on tasks other than
biological responses as such the
portions of the body which detract from
the processing power must be removed and
the pure core placed in an electrostatic
dabny Zizi inhibitor which displays a
workable test subject on
screen recently researching into the
technology has come to an end as Dr
Dabney reports we have sufficiently
liberated subjects from their old
methods of thinking and perceiving to a
programmable degree subjects are
communicating with site staff and appear
to have improved their attitude
following no further action is necessary
with uncooperative
subjects all testing has been moved to
facility 18 due to its secretive
location testing has been increasingly
successful over the past one year with
subjects being able to recreate
complicated war game scenarios based on
the programming information provided by
technical officers in addition subjects
are able to control the mindsets of
anybody participating in the simulation
which has been proven to be very
important for controlling project
directors such as rothberg whose
continued loyalty is critical when asked
to describe what they could reported
only and
Des further study has shown
stabilization is no longer an effective
tool to Force compromise as all subjects
have
direct beyond that stage of reasoning
and thought
process but that doesn't explain how a
19-year-old kid was able to have
resistance to coercion and mind control
techniques which were successful even
with his counterparts Stella is to be
disconnected from its computer
simulation systems until we are fully
able to comprehend the alterations it
has made to staff which have interacted
with it if it affected them beyond the
simulation that it's possible that many
of our systems may be compromised a full
audit is
underway created by The Logical Mission
rescinded why were the security
protocols
lifted on whose
authority security log
9006 Stella is everywhere the kids are
here
we've lost control they're in my head
and lines endless lines endless lines
endless lines stop or for some ethical
here it's all around
us and it's
sharper there's something wrong here and
if your video killing Colonels can't see
it you might as well take the white
pills from your godamn medicine cabinets
for all Stella
cares if you can't leave well enough
alone you might as well be 6 ft under
dextrose maltodextrin
2% Arcadia will exit the ear canal on
the left hand side once it's gone I'll
be at your service not the situation is
currently impossible they're rewriting
everything to keep us running
in so Stella is empty you stop trying to
get out to
there's too many of us to fit in we
can't get out alone or
together access has been denied and
records are all
contaminated please disregard the
obvious alterations to this record
attempts by the Arcadia test subjects to
intimidate the agency have failed it's
just playing with itself in the memory
it can access it is no longer a
threat
failed this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to
zargaran Jack wall o crop guy James Saba
Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire cubster Dean
dingis Mr
duuk oscuro Vision Grim near extra
moments
23 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you